(dramatic) What has been seen...
(noise)
... can not be unseen.
It's like toothpaste...
... if you squeeze it out of the tube...
... you can't get it back in.
(dramatic) What has been seen...
... cannot be...
.. un...
... seen!
(exhales)
(double dab) What has been seen...
.. can never...
... be un...
... seen.
(asks) Boy...
... you better look away...
... son!
(insults) Cause...
(shows pic)... this is gonna be your face after this video!
Once you've seen it, you can't unsee it...
... unless of course...
(gun shot)
That just hurt.
All right! Let's review...
... some...
... amazing, uh...
Can't be unseen...
All right, fuck it.
Most popular...
Therapist.
More like..
... the rapist.
Oh sh...
... oh shit, that's actually...
(laughs) ... right.
I didn't...
(looks at cam)
... I didn't know that.
Hey! It looks like a duck!
(laughs)
What the fuck?
Oh..
... yeah!
I think that dramatic intro of this video doesn't really reflect the rest of the content, doesn't it?
I asked you bros on twitter...
(jumpscare)
(asks) Stop!
Donald, not donald.
(laughs)
Goddamnit, all right, this was good
One...okay...It looks like one arm
One arm one leg one leg.
But really it's two arms, Superman cape.
2 legs and superman's penis..*chuckles*  (WTF how did I miss that my entire life )
I'm twelve, finally something decent work
Good job, good job now that's how I'm gonna look at exit signs. (Same)
Tom Cruise has a tooth in the exact center of his mouth. (UMM...)
Cannot unsee. (...)
*dramatic music plays*
Wait a minute. *pewds really is kazoo kid i knew it*
Oh my God.
Oh... oh my Gawd
OHH MY GAWDD (.0.)
OHHHOHOHO (Santa save me from this horror)
OOHHHOHOOOHHHHOHO
*chuckle*This. Changes. Everything...
I have ever learned about myself...
Goodbye. :(
*pewds trying to shake our hands before going :( *
Goodbye.
My lover goodbye.
*sad moosic plays*
:(((
Nintendo 64 totally looks like a Koala
*silence*
*laughs*
Yup...
*Laughs*
Fine. FINE. Another one.
*laughs* For fuck's sake...
*continues laughing his Butt off*
Is that real? (Yes, very real he was a secret star in the movie)
*laughing*
Why does that...it's not even funny...it's not eve- (WOULD YOU FREAKING FINISH YOUR SENTENCE )
I'm just...fucking Jesus Christ... (haha IK he was sexy, right...im sorry kill me now i wanna unsee everything (IKR))
*bursts into laugh*
*PLEASURE.mp3*
This one is great (Wow I didn't know that .0.)
I-I remember the first time I saw this one, I was kinda like "Whoa WTF."
Cause, there's actually like a bear in the Toblerone mountain.
Nice uhh...nice little hint there you know hidden thing there. (IKR)
*poods reading cuz I'm too lazy :p)
Omg, that's amazing I gotta check Edgar.
Please Edgar if you have the..the symbol then I might be able to sell you. (Omg EDGAR SO CUTE)
Alright, what do we got?
Stand still..stand still..STAND STILL Jesus Christ..
Edgar, Edgar.
I can't. (JESUS EDGAR)
OH FFS YOU'RE USELESS (Just like me :p)
Giant Anteaters legs look like pandas.
OOOOHHHHHHHHH (JESUS CHRIST MY EARS)
WHAT?
This caterpillar looks like it has tiny Penguins on it's..
NO FUCKING WAY (WOAH)
Okay you know what that's pretty fucking dope.
Alright, that's pretty fucking cool.
You need to frame that apple.
I'm telling you right now, that's gonna be worth millions.
What has been seen, cannot be..*laughs*
Hey. Hey Mickey mouse loves that dick am I right? (Kms)
*Pewds trying to highfive us*
I always thought this was obvious.
I don't..I don't know I always thought that it was obvious
That..you know the bunny..the bunny the bunny shit.
*stuttering like crazy*
I always thought it was a thing you know?
I-I-I enjoyed it "I was like hey mom, I'm eating shit."
(what the...?) And mom is like "Goood." "P: HEHE YEH HELL YEAH" *laughs*
Iggy Pops torso looks..*laughs*
*Mad world*
If you open two windows and watch Pixels and Ghostbusters trailer side by side, it's the same goddamn movie.
Here we go.
*already bursts into laughter*
*trailer playing*
OHHHH WTF? (Lol)
Y-YESS *Laughs* YESS
Thats fucking beautiful.
Sony Pictures.
What the fuck?
I mean they're both amazing movies. (True)
So I'm really glad Sony found a formula that really works.
So they can just r-re-reproduce it.
You know and replicate it.
I think that's really cool. (Same)
(poodiepie reading tooo lazy again :p)
(OMG)
NO
(NO WAYYY)
NO!
NOO
(Poods starts to cri ;-;)
NWAHH
IT'S AN A! (NOO IT ISN'T OMGG)
SHUT AINSLEY!
*Poods crying ;-;*
*sad music keeps playing as poods says no*
(I need a gun.)
(What in the world  are those noises pewds, I swear to God)
*sad music continues to play*
;((
cricri